foreign
[Music]
well that was two times hard for me
try it out
[Music]
foreign
uh striking range and uh yes
every Tech every Aikido technique is
like that
okay so the
the takeaways is you have to be in the
UK Center that's kazushi okay they
should they should never be even even if
they happen to look like they're
standing still
uh you should be in their Center
and then
they're still in kazushi but you should
try not to have them stand still
okay
um
and then secondarily
they're always going forward
and as you're doing a spiral rotation
eventually
they're going to end up going the other
direction because of the circular nature
of the technique okay so first the wrong
way
is I go here and I'm not in his Center
he waits there they get in the back
I throw
and then so look he he went this way
and then I opened
and then he goes back where he came from
I don't want to do that
I'm going to keep him moving keep him
moving
in
and here I don't bring him back
when he presses up
right he's driving up I don't go back he
drives up I take it forward
until eventually he goes the other way
you if I try to take him back
and doing what he wants
or
I'm trying to hold him down
you just take it Forward okay so again
he's moving
in his Center in his Center in his
Center into the kazuchi he gets up don't
go here
he gets up you keep it going forward
in his Center in his Center he gets up
squish forward
Center Center centers forward
let's try
it so if I go here he's never gonna wait
there for you
as I'm not in his Center okay but let's
pretend
and then now I get him again
all right
and then I opened here
and you'll feel like you have great
Leverage
okay maybe on him but he is stronger
than me don't let me throw you backwards
you got it
snow it's not gonna work
but even if I was Stronger
do you see how he
stopped
and now I'm pushing him
that's a energetic violation
do you understand and so my time then
miss the misogi from my town dead
functioning as kihon wants me to it's
done I actually polluted it okay
so
watch
then if I know let me let me ask you
if I know on the final arm the final
test of Aki I can't push him what does
that mean must be achieved before that
arm is used
say it again he's falling he's already
falling that way do you understand so as
as I come around in his Center
here
off down
he gets up
I he
you see
just like
I do poke you whole I can't go
here he has to already be falling that
way exactly the same thing okay so
um
foreign
there it is right there
okay
so what I want you to do now
is either leave out the arm
the young arm
or
make it later
[Music]
either leave take it out or make it
later
sir
okay so he he disconnects his Center
you see if you went for an external
shoulder manipulation
right and then when I ask any questions
or comments you didn't have anything
okay the external manipulation is is
what you're trying not to do anymore
okay so he's a opportunity you see not
an obstacle okay so he's gonna grab
right and you you might not be able to
go
as fast as you want it does that's not
important
so I don't need to go here
's where I am
here's where I touch and that moves him
he's he don't he doesn't want to move
that knee you see but that doesn't
matter look do you see do you see how
I'm doing that every time he he you
could feel what he doesn't want to but
it's triggering you and you're like also
I can make you it doesn't matter okay
well here we are now and now you can see
he wants to go that way
we pay attention right
so but that's gonna help the adhesion
here he's trying to go that way you see
go that way it helps the adhesion
because he's he's feeding it so the same
thing when I'm here
he you can put your arm down there you
see well now I just work with that point
because if she's over here now
you see when I still pull his Center
do you see he went to his elbow go go
back with your hand was
where was I going here he put his elbow
down what does that tell you where I'm
gonna go now over here
do you see that but not his head his
body
you see then he's going to get up
and I'm not gonna stop him or hook him
he's gonna get up and I bring It Forward
you see the same thing here I don't
crush him I feel his Center watch watch
his center of gravity
you feel that sir do you see
okay does he know how to do that again
he does not know
that he's not taking a
game of throne do you see that
difference
take advantage of these opportunities
okay especially if they're followed up
with any questions
okay